recaptures the trouble we're to shoot
[Music]
[Applause]
you are a cheat code but stay Twitter
and this new open quick shot to hit the
glass and win in great weights at mid
floor now gets into it with five four
from the logo yes
conquer betray walk three pulls off time
on Boston 311 to play bass tips on the
gaskets through the lane bounced to the
cutting peppery picked up bruto out to
dre long bob perfecto
and again Holliday is in the lane the
best shooters out there in the middle of
the floor
[Music]
that's adjust and there's nobody out
there I mean here all day to shoot this
like three or four shots here is coming
up tipped pray
[Applause]
ten assists see where this baby comes
from he wasn't even on the logo he was
beyond the logo good heavens
Dre keep on with another addition to the
highlight reel
[Applause]
but Trey waits for the screen gets the
contact this is a chance for Trey
Young's fourth four-point play of the
year I - bye y'all
and Butler track tie game and my ma
takes a timeout
[Applause]
and they continued let who and now they
starting to switch out there man Oh logo
man strikes again they're trying to keep
it under trays hands they cannot he gets
the three away that's it with point five
Trey young puts Atlanta ahead 92 to 91
and then he sidesteps embiid gets the
three ball off beats the buzzer and the
Hawks and the leaves on Long's baseline
Graham gets rid of it here's Trey
24 portray young first foul on Graham
Trey couldn't really see the feet but
didn't trust me it was on the logo there
you go look at that amazing range pike
scores on the board in this first half
Wow three threes for Trey young and logo
man makes his return yeah he's one step
past half court and lets it fly finished
hard at the rim
tray
[Applause]
backheel may have been on the logo over
the line you're considered in was there
a little daylight on the back of the
foot and this is a two point ballgame
Trey young from inside the logo at
midcourt he drained that bad boy and
then Randall after a Miss at the other
end another look at the logo three and
then after the Randall best trait took
it coast-to-coast